Welcome back everyone, maximum effort big surprise,
Ryan Reynolds released a brand-new Deadpool
trailer crossover with the MCU court.
Because he's promoting another movie.
But doing it is a sort of Deadpool in the
MCU kind of trailer.
So we'll break it all down.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs here.
Obviously he take shots at himself at the
marvel movies at all the Disney plus stuff
Kevin Feige pretty much all the marvel actors
in general.
I will be doing more Deadpool 3 videos because
they're in the middle of making that movie right now
if you're wondering.
They haven't talked about it in a while, but
he does actually mentioned Deadpool 3 a couple
times during this trailer video.
If you're new to the channel, be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there's obviously a
bunch of marvel Disney plus stuff coming up
with the Loki finale in then there's all the
other marvel Disney plus shows are coming
later this year.
I do love how he jokes that court was like
his last pick like he was my first choice.
But all the other marvel actors were busy
on Disney plus.
Just joking about all the marvel Disney plus
shows they're making right out all of them
movie actors that are doing those the funny
quote that Ryan Reynolds gave when he released
this is the if you include Deadpool's cocaine
writer.
This is the most expensive reaction video
ever made.
So they're also playing this as if Deadpool
has his own YouTube channel inside the MCU
or inside the Deadpool movies and he releases
these videos on the regular the joke he goes
out on half the penny of you for this crap
is just a joke about him having a super low
CPM on his YouTube videos.
Probably because he so graphic he swear so
much just a joke about censorship in general on Youtube
He's also calling this promo Deadpool maximum
reactions with this is a video series the
Deadpool himself has been doing for a while
so I'm hoping is is that when they actually
finish making Deadpool three selection just
have Deadpool portal code hijack to take over
Ryan Reynolds real life YouTube channel and
use that to release a lot of the viral promos
but the other big reason why they're doing
this to promote that movie that he made with
Taika Waititi free guy is because they may
that movie a fox just as they were finishing
the Fox Disney buyout deal.
So that's why he's making fun of this movie.
Saying it feels like it's kind of like the
last days of Foxfire sale situation.
Because after Disney finished buying Fox.
There were all these Fox movies that they
were in the middle of making it Disney had
decide which ones to can which ones to finish
making in this was just one of the once they
opted to finish and release.
So they kind of ran into a new mutant situation
with Ryan Reynolds new movie.
Because Fox is now Disney, so technically
this is Disney releasing a fox movie.
Even though Ryan Reynolds made it a fox before
the Disney buyout is also what he's making
of the trademark infringement jokes when the
free guy trailer starts shouting out from
the studio that may Deadpool because technically
Disney now owns the Deadpool trademark amateur
surprised that they paid money to do the full
motion capture special effects for court and
its court going to Deadpool's house.
Like his little shack that is living in now
inside the Deadpool universe.
They take a ton of shots at Ryan Reynolds
in the Deadpool movies.
In addition to making fun of all the marvel
movies Kevin Feige and making fun of Taika
Waititi in the Thor movies as well.
He says that Ryan Reynolds is me.
Which is super insulting to him as Deadpool
the character.
Like how dare Ryan Reynolds play me in a movie.
I love how Deadpool asks him how you break
into the MCU in court also makes is huge marvel
burned by saying you basically have to fail
at achieving your dream after trying over and over.
Then you die inside a little and then all
you have to do is wait for your agent to call
and maybe he'll have a new job for you inside
the MCU.
Which is also them making fun of a lot of
the really big actors in the MCU having trouble
doing non-marvel movies that they develop
themselves.
And because it was happening with the marvel
phase 4 movies.
They're also making fun of a lot of the newer
Hollywood actors that are just now joining
the MCU movies like the Eternals movie has
a ton of big stars and it.
You wouldn't have normally expected to be
in a marvel movie.
Like Angelina Jolie was she doing in a marvel
movie.
The whole burn that they make on Deadpool
to about fringing when they talk about Jodie
Comer's character say that they hope that
she doesn't get foraged in this new movie
is a reference to what happened to Vanessa
during Deadpool to.
They killed her off really quickly the beginning
of Deadpool to him became part of Deadpool's
motivation during the movie.
In fact, she actually seem like she had less
to do in that movie that she did in the first Deadpool film
But I think they've already confirmed that
Vanessa is coming back in Deadpool three.
I think they're gonna basically fix all that
so she will ask you have more to do in Deadpool 3
They did say some of the actors from the Deadpool
Fox movies will come into Deadpool 3 into
the MCU if you look in the background to there
is a bunch of random Easter eggs all over
the place not really specific Easter eggs,
but they're playing this is if it's Deadpool
shack in his apartments from the first couple
of Deadpool movies are just full of all kinds of junk
But the way they're filming this it also looks
kind of like they used Ryan Reynolds house
in real life, because he uses his house to
film a lot of his promos for his YouTube channel
their if you seen any the interviews that
he's done in the past year.
It looks like he's in this log cabin looking
place that's actually part of his house in
real life in New York is this giant house
Ray also films a lot of the smaller stuff
like your seeing right here in the trailer
is a random manikin hand in the background
big pumpkins leather bag full of junk couple
of high school trophies those that she might
be Ryan Reynolds real life.
High school trophies in some of the other
modern camera gear like the ring like the
scene the background is probably just camera
gear that Ryan Reynolds uses when filming
himself if you remember the first look from
Thor love and thunder.
They released a while ago with Taika Waititi
and Chris Hemsworth this Thor and Corey if
you show him without his motion capture.
But he's in court's costume you notice that
this is his costume from Thor Ragnarok.
Even though the done filming the Naka to release
the movie till next year's with either holding
off on releasing a bunch of promos and stuff
for that till way later this year.
But the whole cabin vibe here is also meant
to remind you of court living with Thor in
his house in new Asgard back during avengers
endgame.
And you notice there's a little game controller
sitting in front of him.
So I think that just another back door reference
to Deadpool being a new master inside the MCU
But this is also their way of Deadpool in
court making fun of Ryan Reynolds free guy
movie implying that it's going to fail he's
going to die inside and then Ryan Reynolds
will wait for the call quota quote from his
agent saying that they're making a Deadpool
movie, which they've already done.
Of course we know they're making Deadpool
three because it's Taika Waititi playing court
reacting to Taika Waititi body saying this
in that free guy movie is sort of like he
saying that he Taika Waititi also failed it
trying to make some other big dreams and then
he waited for his agent and that's how he
wound up directing Thor Ragnarok in Thor love and thunder
I know a lot of people are wondering if the
whole Deadpool in the MCU's can have something
to do with doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness because with the Loki series now like
we have the Loki finale this coming out in
their just completely messing with the timeline
in the multiverse and really crazy ways.
And we have the marvel what if series, which
is another big multiverse series were also
a lot of rumors about the plot of Spider-Man
no way home doing a multiverse version of
the sinister 16 during Loki episode one miss
minutes also makes a reference when talking
with the sacred timeline about how the multiverse.
If they don't maintain the sacred timeline
will devolve into chaos, it will turn into madness
Which is meant to be a direct reference to
the plot of doctor strange 2 multiverse of
madness where you start to see a lot of realities,
overlapping crossing over with each other.
So even though we don't know completely how
Doctor strange is going to be pulling all
these different people from alternate universes
to the main MCU universe is one of the ways
that Marvel is sort of bringing a lot of these
Fox characters into the MCU.
Although most of the X-Men characters for
instance at the core X-Men characters will
just straight up be rebooted with brand-new
MCU versions of the characters that doesn't
mean that Deadpool is going to show up during
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness.
It just means they're going to rely on a lot
of those multiverse tropes to explain how
he crosses over into the MCU.
And because it's Deadpool he can also comment
on how none of it makes sense.
Like wait a minute where my now my inside
the MCU was going on also calls himself the
Canadian Benedict Cumberbatch another doctor
strange reference when he says he thinks that
the free guy movie was not worth diverting
Ryan Reynolds mind away from making Deadpool
three in the way they play the joke Deadpool
knows that they're making a new movie about
him and is trying to get it made faster and
when he starts making fun of Corgan Taika
Waititi saying that he prefers dark world.
He's talking about Thor the dark world because
that was the last movie before Taika Waititi
took over the Thor films the big thing with
Deadpool 3 is that the probably not gonna
start filming that to either the very end
of this year or next year and I'm expecting
next year means they will be able to release
it before 2023, but that might wind up being 2024
So don't be surprised if it's a couple more
years before we ask you see Deadpool three
the latest movie that we know about this coming
out in the timeline of marvel phase 4 is the
fantastic four movie in that's basically going
to be summer 2023.
It seems like the only other movies that we
know about for sure after that are going to
be the Blade movie, but they didn't put that
in that big promo they released earlier this year
So you know exactly that's gonna be released
in the pie be later in 2023.
Everybody is let me know in the comments what
you think about them doing these Deadpool MCU Trailers now
I feel like they should have been doing
this a long time ago, but my next big video
will be for the Loki episode 6 finale that
will post Wednesday just like normal.
I got a whole bunch of bonus videos plan for
later this week.
If you have any big request for special marvel
videos.
Let me know in the comments there are supposed
to be a couple big trailers in the next couple
weeks as well in then all the marvel what
if episodes will start and I'll be doing full
episode videos for that to everyone click
here for my Loki deleted scenes video for
Loki versus frog Thor and click here for my
full Loki episode 5 video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and maximum effort!